if there's one thing that's worse than
twitches chat it has to be twitches
bands and every week there seems to be a
new one to talk about but why do people
care about them so much well it's
probably because they're capable of
ending careers or revitalizing them
leaving someone irrelevant or making
them a superstar yeah cut the bathroom
scene Oh okay so twitch bands are kind
of a misnomer everyone calls them bands
when really that's just one part of a
three-pronged system if you break
twitches guidelines you get a warning
which can escalate to a temporary
suspension further followed by an actual
band and in theory it's a good system
after all it offers streamers a chance
to redeem themselves after being
involved in shitty situations on top of
giving these stars a shot at making
amends the system keeps bad apples off
twitch ensuring that it remains safe for
everyone I love everyone except cats
according to twitch you're not allowed
to break the law while streaming and on
top of that you can't do things like
impersonate someone steal email
addresses harass people or post porn
which all sounds pretty reasonable well
that's your opinion the issue is that in
practice twitches system appears to be
more forgiving of the platform's marquee
streamers than its up and comers and
it's mostly because it wasn't designed
for a world where streamers are
basically celebrities making it seem
extremely out-of-date anyway
for a pretty huge chunk of twitches
history no one really cared or even
thought about bands although for some
reason more people were googling twitch
bands in August 2010 than in parts of
2013 raising the question who is the
time traveler googling twitch bands
three years before they were even
invented
anyway unlike today during twitches
formative years streaming was just a
hobby and not a viable career path and
as a result the consequences of being
banned or suspended from it we're far
less impactful than they are now back
then if you were slapped with a
punishment bite which you must have done
something stupid something really stupid
like zillion Opie a popular paraplegic
Wow streamer who as it turned out wasn't
really paralyzed at all one zillion
scandal came to twitch his attention
they permanently shut down his channel
and reimbursed his subscribers twenty
thousand dollars while the band system
might have worked effectively in that
case it's mainly because the platform
was far smaller and easier to police
back then but after being bought for
almost a billion dollars back in 2014
twitch completely transformed streaming
into a lucrative business model and with
everyone on the platform competing for
eyeballs being taken out of the spa like
or even a couple days can mean lost
income subs and more importantly
relevance with so much being at stake
you think that people are only being
banned for good reasons right wrong take
a learn for example a popular streamer
who was dealt a copyright strike by
twitch for being near someone blasting a
song over pub G proximity chat so
[__] precious more ridiculous than
the fact the situation wasn't learns
fault is that she received the penalty a
full year after the clip was made
copyright strikes bring in the second
part of twitches banning system a
three-strike process that can result in
a permanent ban regardless of intent on
top of liberally handing out copyright
strikes over the last couple years
twitch has seen an influx of
questionable suspensions people's
channels have been temporarily shut down
for things they didn't say [__]
neighbors
in Word what I said yikers what Grayson
said yikes and I said yikers
but for sporting stupid custom skins oh
my god I have their own scheme only and
even for cosplay Rob welcome meanwhile
some of twitches biggest names rarely
get more than a slap on the wrist for
blatantly breaking the rules
you've got people feeding their pets
alcohol having not so accidental
wardrobe malfunctions and jackasses
nonchalantly dropping racial slurs on
[__] get it you can suck it
might be peeve all with little to no
consequences and look people
occasionally [__] up it's just what we
do which is something twitches attempted
to consider you look at the context and
then we choose based on that whether you
violated the guidelines at all because
the guidelines you know if you didn't
intend eight in our opinion you haven't
violated the guidelines okay that kind
of makes sense we very specifically take
context and intent into account so if
someone walks up to you on the street
and shoves you that's one thing if
someone walks on down the street and
they trip and they push you
it might look if - so an outsider
looking at the video of that action like
it looks the same but it's not the same
wait what 90% of the time I have no idea
what the [__] I'm talking about
that's right twitch the biggest
streaming platform in the Western world
is subjectively evaluating violations of
their Terms of Service by exercising
terrible metaphors and it's because of
this unreliable system that two people
committing the same offense can receive
completely different punishments
Jason you can't play games on company
time but Collins playing - I thought it
was okay
yeah but Colin is popular how many
followers do you have how many videos
have you hosted this week none yeah
that's what I thought pack your bags
Jason you're fired
[Music]
needless to say twitch is walking a
dangerous tightrope with this approach
and while some big streamers have
received significant disciplinary action
in some cases they've actually benefited
from it just look at dr. disrespect who
following his bathroom blunder used his
absence from the platform as a way of
building hype for his eventual return
ladies and gentlemen of the champions
club the two-time is back
at the end of the day all people want is
some consistency so twitch please get
your [__] together and update your
guidelines to reflect the scale of your
platforms growth but more importantly
ensure that every streamer is held to
the same standard regardless of their
follower count what that dear Myles
hackett we've received a notice of
alleged copyright infringement fraud
inappropriate language and general
shittiness in your videos stop your
dangerous slander of twitch or we will
be forced to take action
see this is exactly why I prefer you to
everyone except cats
[Music]